well
the policy that i put forward was
misrepresented and i wanted to make sure
that our important frontline workers
like doctors and teachers weren't
worried that's why i cancelled the
policy i did it straight away i was
decisive and i was honest with the
public about what i was doing
if it's misrepresented rather than the
wrong policy can't you reshape it and
reenact it
i'm very clear we're not proceeding with
this policy what's important to me is
that we support people at this difficult
economic time by reversing the national
insurance rise by getting rid of the
green energy levy to save people money
on their fuel bills and that will be my
focus as prime minister
regarding the first minister of scotland
you said she should be ignored and that
she's seeking attention is that your
view of the first minister of wales is
he seeking attention and should he be
ignored the reality is that wales has
been let down by 20 years of labour rule
and what i am about is about making sure
we bring opportunity investment to wales
that we back wales fantastic farmers and
that's what i'm going to be talking
about in the hustings tonight you're not
making any comments about attention
seekers
no i i i believe mark drakeford has not
delivered for the people of wales and i
will be holding him to account
on taiwan would you as prime minister
what approach would you take or what do
you think should happen regarding that
is controversy over the visit by nancy
pelosi
well i do not
support
china's
inflammatory language on this issue it's
perfectly reasonable what is taking
place and i urge china to de-escalate
final question on the nhs it came up a
couple of times in the questions in the
uh hall there
how can you put it right people saying
it's failing it's creaking and that was
happening under tory rule
well we know that the nhs has really
done a brilliant job over covid but
there is a severe backlog now that we're
facing it's difficult to get a gp
appointment difficult to get a dentist
appointment ambulance waiting times are
far too long particularly in rural areas
so what i would do as prime minister is
make sure we are empowering the front
line more we're reducing the central
dictates reducing the layers of
management so we can allow our fantastic
doctors and nurses to get on with their
very important jobs are you looking
forward to being prime minister
i am not taking anything for granted
there is still a long way to go in this
leadership election and what i'm about
is unleashing opportunity across the
united kingdom getting our economy
growing and delivering for people all
over the country